hi Kristen how are you I'm wonderful how
are you this better than I deserve of
how can I help
well currently my husband and I are
trying to tackle some your baby steps
we're new to it but I've been listening
to you for about four months now and I'm
madly in love with your philosophy and
how to tackle that currently we have
about 98 thousand worth of debt together
that's not including our house we have
two little boys ranging in ages 7 and 3
and or two and we're looking to add
another one to the family I kinda have
to point my life or I wanted he's done
having babies that I love being a mommy
and we're looking to maybe start next
year though we're only a baby except to
still have a lot of debt and obviously
savings would be really cheesy err to
set ourselves up for success I have
another baby I'm just kind of not sure
what to do do we wait it out of the air
or - I told most of our debts knocked
out or did we just go ahead and say hey
let's do it with us so young and we'll
keep going on with your program and
hopefully manage it somehow okay so what
does your husband make a year
fifty and you have 98 thousand dollars
and what kind of debt credit cards and a
car how much do you owe on your car we
recently actually just trade it in and
upgraded for a minivan so what kind of
setup for a bigger family so we're at
about 43,000 well that was pretty
freakin stupid yeah I know
so sell the van half of your debt and
you want to have babies half of your
debt
was a stupid van right and you called a
talk radio host to ask permission to
have babies because you bought a van you
couldn't afford i'm fussing at you
you're feeling it okay i mean really you
just traded the right to have children
financially for a van so trade back
trade back the reason this doesn't make
sense in your mind and in your heart is
you're overwhelmed with that and you're
worried about whether or not you can
afford to do this and the reason you
can't afford to do this is you bought
off the hand you couldn't afford right
conclusions real simple sell the van
well I work too and I make Commission on
top of what I bring home monthly salary
and commissions can range from man you
can't afford and so you're having to ask
in your own mind and then asking me
whether you can afford to have children
and the reason you're asking the
question is your pinched and the reason
you're pinched is you bought a van you
can't afford right that's the bottom
line here and so yeah I think you ought
to have kids are you going to quit when
you have kids no no I love working and
also being a mom great okay so get a
$5,000 van and sell this van it was a
really dumb idea you doubled your
consumer debt all in the name of babies
that aren't even here yet and a place to
carry them in a car you can't afford
it's just nuts you even knew that
because you know what you said when I
asked you about it my husband's gonna
kill me well he's gonna kill me on how
it all happened I went in for an oil
change you came out with a minivan sir
but to be honest I was doing it in an
effort to have a reliable car because
previous cars were all used and were not
reliable and costing me a fortune
they didn't cost you forty thousand
but I looked at this man is gonna help
Darla I don't think I gotta help you
okay I mean I'm not gonna argue with you
about this anymore this is a this is a
dumb move you can't really justify it
you can't really rationalize it if
you're not gonna undo it I can't help
you okay you do what you want to it's
okay you're an adult you're allowed to
do what you want to do but I'm not it's
absolutely absurd the whole process was
absurd how you got there was weird the
decision was absurd the fact that you're
now worried about having kids because
you made this decision is absurd and
then the fact that you don't want to
undo the decision is absurd so that
that's what you're facing kiddo so you
got to decide you decide what you're
gonna do here you'll have kids gonna
have a van because it's really tough for
you to afford both that's why you called
me because you were feeling that pinch
not because you actually needed my
permission to have kids that's that's
crazy you know you don't need my
permission to have kids so hey thanks
for the call